bonjour
[Music]
only 20
foreign
thank you eric the european commission
has
today adopted two adequacy decisions for
the united kingdom
one under the general data protection
regulation and one under the law
enforcement directive personal data
can now flow freely from the european
union
to the united kingdom where it benefits
from an essentially
equivalent level of protection to that
guaranteed
under eu law the uk's
data protection system continues to be
based on the same rules that were
applicable
when the uk was a member state of the eu
both adequacy findings of course include
strong
safeguards such as a sunset clause
for the first time in an adequacy
decision which limits the duration
of adequacy to four years
following the green light from member
states representatives the adoption
of the commission today is the last step
in the procedure
the two adequacy decisions enter into
force today
thank you very much christian now i will
call dan
for an announcement on new vat rules
across
europe yes thanks very much eric i hope
you can hear me and i hope you can see
me
indeed this thursday the 1st of july new
vat rules for online shopping will enter
into force now these rules are part of
the eu's
overall efforts to ensure a more level
playing field
when it comes to our businesses to
simplify cross-border e-commerce
and to introduce greater transparency
for eu shoppers when it comes to pricing
and consumer
choice these new rules will affect
online sellers
marketplaces platforms both inside and
outside the european union
it will also affect postal operators
couriers customs and tax administrations
as well as very importantly
consumers we are organizing a technical
briefing today at three o'clock so if
you're interested in this please do tune
in
and we also have a press release
available for you online thank you
thank you very much dan
[Music]
now to end this series of announcements
i would like
to say farewell to our dear colleague
virena schmidt
verena you have been the dpa bureau
chief
in brussels here since 2016 so for
five years i got to know you right
at the beginning of my tenure here in
the spp when you invited me to your
offices
across the road to meet the team
it's less than 10 years two years ago
but it already
feels like half a lifetime as far as i'm
concerned
and i'm sure that um for you these five
years have also been
very very intense so a change of
perspective
will certainly be very welcome
you are now moving on to the dpa
headquarters
as special correspondent for berlin and
eastern germany
as i understand and i would like to
thank you in my name
and in the name of the whole spp for
excellent
cooperation which has always been
both demanding and very cordial
as it should be i wish you
best of luck in your new post don't
forget us
brussels is never far away
and as you know many people come back so
this is only
an au vida certainly not an adu
let me welcome as well um anza haze in
his new role as bureau chief as of
the first of august now remember anza
august is a sacred month
here in brussels so take it easy the
first weeks of your new tenure
that concludes our statements
for today and we will now move to your
questions and i
passed the floor to adam
a very good morning uh good afternoon to
you eric
i wonder as we head towards the summer
holiday season
as you just mentioned there um there
will be a lot of people
in the united kingdom who would love to
have some clarity
about where in the eu they could make
a holiday do you think we are anywhere
near
having an eu wide system to give real
clarity
about who can go where when
when with what requirements
thank you this would be a question first
for
albert and then perhaps for christian
thank you very much adam i hope you can
hear me okay
so regarding the restriction on
non-essential travel from outside the eu
there is a council recommendation in
place which
uh very clearly outlines what um member
states
should be doing in relation to allowing
entry
uh into the eu for travelers from from
the outside the situation
that applies to the united kingdom at
present is that
travelers who are vaccinated who are
fully vaccinated
or who have an essential reason to come
to the eu
should be allowed by member states to
to arrive into the eu uh it so happens
that uh this is something that
the the council keeps under constant
review uh
and there are uh discussions every two
weeks uh in
uh different council structures to
assess what
uh if any changes are need to be made to
this
um to this recommendation and um i can
i can also add that from the commission
side we of course expect member states
to um apply this recommendation uh fully
when it comes to the provision of
information uh what we have done
uh in the commission is we put in place
a website called reopen eu
where we put all the information that we
receive from member states as regards
um different travel restrictions that
are in place and we will of course
continue to do so
christian you want to have some yes if i
maybe can add on the
on the internal side in the european
union
i mean let me remind you of course of
our
eu digital corporate certificate which
will be the key tool
for allowing safe
traveling this summer and
which is well on track with more and
more member states
connecting to the system we have
we will have to the regulation entering
into force on the first
of july so later this week and as of
then
we will have all the binding rules in
place for all member states but i think
we also see
convergence in that direction by many
member states when it comes
to the to the conditions for traveling
and easing travel restrictions in
a safe
and responsible way of course
and then we of course also have the
recommendation
in place on free movement which
was adopted by the council mitchum
and so this commissioner's position is
that we can be confident now that with
the with the updated recommendation and
with the
certificate conditions are there for
europeans
to enjoy a safe
summer holiday with hopefully limited
travel restrictions recommendation is
very clear it's fully vaccinated and
recovered citizens
should be exempted from trouble-related
restrictions
it also clarifies the rules as you will
remember for
for families ensuring family unity and
exempting children
from certain from certain requirements
and at the same time of course it
includes an emergency break which is
important
in the context of course of possible new
variants that we're also
seeing or could be seeing in the future
again
to be able to react swiftly to any to
any development in that
sense thank you
christian are there other comments or
questions rather sorry
on this issue of traveling within the eu
this summer please only keep your hand
raised if your question
is on this
hans you have a question on this
yes hello eric i've actually got a bunch
of questions but one of
uh it uh concerns actually the travel um
from outside into the eu
and it's concerning the vaccines handed
out by the covex program because as i
understand a large part
of those vaccines are astrazeneca jabs
produced
in india and as i further understand
they are not approved by
emma and so since the eu is basically a
huge uh supporter of the kovacs
program and many countries in the world
or many citizens and many countries
across the world are getting
vaccinated with these jabs and then
can't travel
into the eu i wonder whether
uh this is not causing a sort of yeah a
problem or an unfairness
in a certain way of course uh these
vaccines need to be approved by
the ema but um i i would like to know
whether the commission is
in a way um aware of this problem does
it have a comment on it and also is
raising it with ima
as to where there could be an approval
for these vaccines given thank you
thank you question for adelberg
thank you hans so as you as you said
yourself
there are two different uh possibilities
um that are mentioned in the council
recommendation
and member states should um open
non-essential travel to
those who have been vaccinated with an
email approved vaccine and they could
uh do so so they have explicitly the
option to do so
for um for people who have been
vaccinated with the vaccine that
received the who emergency
authorization now um for
for the specific uh question that you're
raising about uh
the uh the vaccines in the that are
present in kovacs
uh i i'm afraid i will have to check and
get back to you
thank you very much let's continue on
the issue
janice
yes thank you uh can you hear me yes go
ahead yes go ahead
great thank you guys for the laws from
kathmarine uh uh two questions um
a is the commission aware of this plan
that has been reported
or this proposal i should say by by
germany
for a coordinated approach the vis-a-vis
third countries which includes a ban on
non-essential travel
of all non-essential travel from from
the uk
is there a concern that if there isn't
coordination on this
then there will be a disruption in the
intra-eu travel
arrangements and i ask in particular
given the announcements from germany
regarding portugal which go into effect
tomorrow uh
about which i also wanted to ask are
they uh compatible
with what is foreseen in the eu covet
certificate once it comes into force
thank you so uh your first question i
think is for adelbere and the second
more
for christian
thank you uh thank you very much uh so
first of all regarding the um the the
the announcements of the possible
or the discussions on the possible
application of
um the emergency break which is
um contained in the council
recommendation this is in fact something
that
um could be discussed by the member
states and the commission
representatives in
the council formation called ipcr uh in
fact
as we speak um so given that ipcr
started this morning at
uh at 11 o'clock i don't yet have uh
updates
or live information as to what's being
discussed in that meeting so i would
maybe suggest that we come back to it
after that that meeting has finished
and generally speaking um there are
there are pretty clear rules in this
council recommendation as to what member
states should be doing
and when it comes to as i said uk
travelers the rule is
uh that that non-essential travel should
be open to
people who have been fully vaccinated
and those who have an essential reason
not to not to other travelers and
from the commission side we very much
expect member states to fully apply that
recommendation
however it is not something that
it is fully uh legally binding on the
member states as would be
a regulation or a directive given that
it is
uh a council recommendation
yeah what i can can add from the
internal side you asked whether we are
aware of this
proposal from germany we are in fact you
have been informed by the german
authorities that they
are planning to consider portugal
as the various various variant area
so this comes in the context of this
emergency break that is foreseen in the
that i've mentioned before in the
council recommendation but i would say
as adults says let's
let's have the discussion
first at the at the expert level and at
the council level i can just
uh say that this is what we have been
informed of
uh at this stage and uh of course that
is important
um for us that the council
recommendation
will continue to be the guiding compass
for all member states in this context
no matter what measures we are talking
about
thank you are there other questions on
this issue
uh yes i just have a little follow-up
for adelberg regarding this indian
vaccine
so as far as understand before this
question wasn't raised
and uh you don't know right now if this
indian astrazeneca
is uh going to be sufficient
to enter to you for a third confidential
nulls or not
so this is my question did i understand
right right now you don't have this
information
yes
that is entirely correct i will have to
check this point and come back to you so
if you're also interested in in this
information i'm very happy to include
you in
our reply to us
okay thank you i see no further
questions
on this issue and therefore i move
to moses
this is related question if you hear me
about the recognition of vaccines for
travel into the air
and has to do with the vaccines
developed by russia
and china which has not been approved i
understand
by emma or not even included on the
on the who emergency list and i wonder
if
there is some kind of loophole in the
council regulation
uh because it seems to allow let's say
uh travelers uh from ao member state
which has approved these vaccines to
travel into another member state
or it is up to that other member state
what is your reaction to that thank you
well i think it's you have very similar
rules actually
um in the in when you look at the
and the your digital corvette
certificate
um it is uh basically
vaccines approved by emma have to be
accepted under the under the
certificate if member states or for
member states when lifting restrictions
for
for travelers and for
other vaccines that might have been
approved by
by certain member states and used
international programs
it is it remains in the hands of
the other member states to see whether
they would want to accept
such a vaccine when it is presented
for for travelling so there is a there
is a very uh similar and aligned
approach actually to what
what we have on the external side with
the
big difference of course that for eu
nationals
vaccines are not a precondition or
vaccination or even the your digital
coverage certificate is not
a precondition for the right to free
movement
this of course remains in place but of
course
the certificate and vaccination or
testing etc
or recovery certificate would help to
facilitate
travel and and be able to to travel
with less restrictions
thank you mosey i thought your question
was on a completely
different subject i guess we'll come
back to that later
are there other questions for us on
the issue of uh travel
in the eu or from third countries into
the eu
please don't keep your hand raised if
this is the case
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
saturn
[Music]
[Music]
yes sorry to come back but i'm slightly
confused with something i heard earlier
about vaccines and intra-eu travel
versus
travel from third countries is it is it
not the case that
member states have the uh are sort of
allowed
to accept non-approved vaccines when it
comes to intra-eu travel
but when it comes to travel from third
countries they
it is strongly recommended that they not
accept any vaccines which are not
approved either by who or by emma
about external external travel and as i
said the
the council recommendation says member
states should
accept those that have approval in the
eu
and they could so they have the option
of accepting those
um that have received w that
have completed who emergency listing
process
so by by elimination it uh
it would seem to imply that member
states are
not recommended not to accept uh the
uh any any other vaccines for for the
purpose of travel
um that's that's what i can say about
the external travel recommendation
thank you so we continue on the issue
atanasius
hi there are two parts in my question
first of all
what happens if one country exceeds the
scope of the recommendation
and accepts right now actively
vaccination certificates
from non-w iho approved vaccines
and secondly there is another issue with
the interoperability of the
eu vaccination certificate covet
certificate
did you know that if you have one dose
of an ema recommended vaccine in one
country one member state
and your second dose and another man or
state those systems don't talk to each
other
and no matter how hard you try you will
not get an au
covered certificate because one system
one country will recognize
the first dose and the other will
recognize the second as first
again and this is not rare this is not
something
that happens uh not very frequently
from the 112 individuals that are
connected right now
i can tell you that at least two have
this
problem so it's a little less than two
percent in our
uh in our uh company right now
so what can be done about it how can you
make
the systems become interoperable
and solve this issue thanks
thank you very much where you see that
real life
is always even more complex that all the
procedures and solutions
we try to put in place um i don't think
that we can provide you with an answer
now but i'm looking at johannes
because this is indeed about the uh the
technical side
uh i guess as well um in terms of
exchange of information between between
systems unless you have a
you have an answer that you can give now
but no we will come back to you on that
once we have looked
into it on your first question i think
it goes back to adelberg
that's that's correct um i cannot tell
you what happens
um what what i can say is that
the the approach that has been agreed by
the council and that
is a recommendation to member states is
very clear it was lost
um updated on the 20th of may and then
afterwards there were revisions of the
of one of the annexes um from our side
we
we urge member states to swiftly
implement this council recommendation in
a fully coordinated manner
christian christian maybe if i can add
just a few words on your on your second
question athanasius
we are we are aware of of this issue and
it has also been flagged
uh to us and we are for sure looking
into this
but uh let's also not forget that the
regulation is not
yet in in application so that there's
still a few more days
for member states to sort things out and
of course
uh the the regulation is quite clear
in the sense that that all
your your vaccinations should be
documented via the eu digital
code certificate so even if you have
only received one
you have in principle the right uh to
have this documented in in your
certificate
so this the legal situation is very
clear and
should hopefully help to to solve also
bureaucratic
hurdles soon alexander
a question on this travel within the eu
or from outside the eu
the decision hi sorry
no my question is in the adequacy
decision actually okay we'll come back
to that later
thanks uh hamid
oh sorry it's not on travel either okay
griselda
criselda paul
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
lorenzo
my first question concerns the the free
movement with
breathing which is not there anymore but
uh
you mentioned the recommendation
concerning
external countries uh third countries
but i remember that there was there were
talks about
the possibility to apply the covet
certificate also
to breed and within with an agreement uh
like with switzerland i know that
switzerland is in the
schengen space but uh uh
is there any uh possibility that uh
a uh between britain and the eu is
successful concerning this coffee
certificate
and another thing how many countries uh
are now connected with the kovis
certificate and which countries are not
not yet connected thanks okay on the
first question christian on the second
uh johannes yeah um
on the uk there are talks on going at
the at the technical level which are
progressing well
and it's going in the right direction
this is particular because uh
the the technical uh system uh
and the architecture of the eu and the
uk are
aligned um the talks are ongoing i have
no specific
timeline to announce
but as you you know we have been open
for working with our international
partners from the very
beginning and designed the whole system
in such a way that this is possible
so it's it's good that the uk is now
working with us towards
that goal of achieving such an
interpretable solution
johannes yes um thank you lorenzo for
the possibility to
opportunity to to update you on the
numbers so we have 20
member states uh connected and issuing
certificates
uh um and i think rather than now um
going towards 20 i can mention the the
seven that are not yet
uh live um but once again we have a
website
which is updated in real time so for
example over the weekend slovene
slovenia and slovakia
joined and this is updated since this
morning so you can also
just go there and uh and look it up
yourselves um
and in addition to 20 you also have
iceland in norway but these are not
member states but european economic area
countries
now on the countries that are not yet
alive
and i'm reading from the webpage so
it's cyprus hungary
ireland malta the netherlands
and romania and sweden
thank you very much johannes are there
other questions for us
on the issue of travel
that does not seem uh to be the case so
thank you very much
there was another question for christian
from catherine
so we move to you catherine hello
uh christian and my question is about
your announcements a moment ago about uh
data adequacy and approval for the uk
i'm
surprised by it you said that i think
you've said that there's a sunset clause
in that
approval of four years and yet we see
that the uk um
had organized the task force on
regulatory
reform to seize the new opportunities
from leaving the
eu and top of their list which is at
least very near the top of their list
is ditching gdpr in favor
of a uk framework for data protection
and they describe gdpr as out of date
that it needs to be revised
um that it goes against innovation and
that its provisions are unnecessary
so if this actually happened uh
would the would the you have to wait to
the end of this four year period or
could it sever
that agreement beforehand thanks yes
um look we are of course very actively
following
um all developments in the uk this is
this is part of the whole
commitment of of the of the adequacy
here
um first first on the sunset clause let
me let me just remind that this is
uh the first time that we are putting
such a sunset clause in an adequacy
decision um this is
particularly a new um a new safeguard
that makes sure that um
yeah that the uk stays
aligned to our to our key to to
ensure an essentially adequate
protection and
this would mean of course that after
these four years this will also have to
go
through the whole process again
that's that led to the adoption of of
the adequacy decision
so this makes this makes it very clear
and shows very clearly from
from the u side that we that we are
serious about
of course the uk continuing
to to accept or to to stay you know on
the on the same on the same line with us
on on data protection um
as for your question you know whether if
if the uk
at any point would decide to deviate
from from gdpr requirements
as for all other adequacy decisions in
case of any problematic developments
that would negatively affect the
level of protection of personal data the
commission can
decide at any point in time to suspend
to terminate
or to amend the decision so this can be
done immediately in case of
justified urgency so
the sunset class does not hinder this in
any way
thank you christian very clear alexander
i think you had a question on the same
issue
indeed thank you um yeah my question um
also concerns the adequacy decision but
more specifically
um the uh the the second decision on law
enforcement
um here uh the uk has been continuously
criticized
for uh the wide-ranging surveillance
powers of its intelligence agencies
and you might recall there was an ecj
[Music]
ruling only last year that said that
these powers were excessive
i tried to look into the document
quickly i couldn't quite find
references to that so i wondered how the
commission considers that the current
adequacy decision adequately
protects european citizens from
uk intelligence agencies surveillance
powers
when courts such as the european court
of justice
the european court of human rights have
consistently found those
powers to be excessive christian
yes on on national security access so
as requested in particular by the case
law of
the court of justice including the
recent
shrimps to judgment we have carefully
assessed the conditions and safeguards
under which the uk law enforcement
authorities or intelligence services
can access data transferred from the eu
our adequacy decision contains a
detailed analysis of these aspects
including the most recent reforms of uk
surveillance regimes that have
significantly strengthened the
applicable safeguards
the uk certainly has significant
capabilities in the area of national
security
as is also the case for some other eu
member state for some eu member states
sorry
but the uk system also has a number of
distinctive features and safeguards that
were introduced
notably following judgments from the
strasbourg and luxembourg
courts first the collection of
data by intelligence bodies is subject
in most cases
to requirement of prior authorization by
an independent judicial body
second the collection of data for
national security purposes is subject to
strict
conditions and safeguards in particular
any
measures needs to be necessary and
proportionate
to the purpose it is intended to achieve
this
necessity and proportionality check is
part of the judicial prior authorization
and then third in the uk system
challenges by individuals against the
intelligence bodies for violation of
fundamental rights
can be brought before a specific court
the investigatory
powers tribunal and last but not least
let me mention you
you mentioned yourself the european
court of human rights
so while the uk has left the eu
and is no longer directly bound by eu
data protection laws
it is still of course
has to adhere to the european convention
of of human rights
and has submitted to the jurisdiction of
the european
court of human rights and also to the
council of europe's
convention 108 which is the only binding
international treaty in the area
of data protection so here the uk
remains
if you want in the european privacy
family
and so there is this is also an
important element to take into account
thank you are there other questions on
the issue
of the adequacy decision
hans
sorry apologies not on the adequacy
decision but it's probably also for
christian
um it is on uh the in uh cross
uh intro across eu uh investment
protection i think that is for him but
uh
is that right no it's not
for him it would be for dan
i think um but let
me see what else we have
i see no other further questions uh for
christians so let me go to tommaso who
had a question
on vaccines
[Music]
me
foreign
[Music]
we come back to your question
yes thank you so for dan then um well
the corporate
observatory europe published a paper
today saying that the commission is
uh preparing um a proposal on intra-eu
investment protection and um that
is this coming in this autumn and that
one of the options apparently considered
in a non-paper from september last year
is to build up an intra-eu
investment court so my two questions
would be first of all can you confirm
that
such a proposal for inter eu investment
protection
is coming uh this fall and uh secondly
um yeah can you comment on uh the report
that
uh yeah i think this non-paper is um
considering such an
building up a an investment court which
is of course controversial
uh given that many people say you should
go to normal courts including investors
should go to normal courts
so yeah what would the commission would
comment on this criticism thank you
thank you
after hearing your question i'm not
entirely sure whether it is
dan or sonia um
let us let us see dan
i'm not sure we have something to
comment at the stage but go ahead
no indeed thanks eric and hi hans thanks
very much for your question
um absolutely look i wouldn't have
anything to comment on in terms of
documents or non-papers or anything like
that
um but i will certainly check and if
there is anything i'll get back to you
after of course checking with colleagues
thank you hans you have a follow-up
yes could i ask on something completely
different if that's fine
no i'm sorry sorry good try but
you know we have lots of people who
raise their hands on different subjects
is there another question on this issue
of
intra-eu investments
no okay then i go back to
[Music]
hamid with the question on pakistan
hello yes go ahead okay
this is khalid farooqi from jio
television news pakistan
i would like to forward my question that
though this question should be directed
to fatf
but since european commission and
european unions many many countries are
member of
fatf so fatf is still
kept pakistan in gray list
and said that they are encouraged by
pakistani progress but
out of 27 26 point have been
compliant now only 27th number 27
left is it not too much of a harsh
punishment for pakistan regarding
counter-terrorism financing and money
laundering
that the list almost have been completed
but they are kept for
for next period of review in grey list
okay thank you very much do you have
another question
sorry i didn't want to interrupt
it's directed to you particularly that
european parliament
in fact passed resolution against
pakistan
gsp plus status with 681 votes
to three and this
request has been made to european
commission and
european council to look at it and
suspend
pakistan gsp plus status
on the ground of discrimination against
minorities
and also misuse of blasphemy laws
so when this decision will be
taken that whether pakistan
would be suspended or gsp plus or
pakistan
status of gsb plus would continue
for pakistan thank you thank you
your first question i believe is for
dan and the second for miriam
yeah absolutely thanks very much eric
and thanks very much
for your question indeed i can answer on
the first leg of your question when it
comes to anti-money laundering
i would start by just saying that
tackling anti-money laundering and
countering terrorist financing is an
absolute priority for the european union
and
for the european commission you will
have seen all the different
um actions that we have taken and
measures that we have put in place over
the past couple of years
we believe this is a really really
important priority both within
the european union but also globally and
that's why we
we continue to work with our
international partners that's why we
continue to cooperate
within the framework of uh fataf the
financial action
task force um which as you rightly point
out is an intergovernmental
organization and for that reason of
course i'm not going to comment
on the measures taken by fata for by the
different types of procedures that are
in place there all
i would state very very generally is
that fighting anti-money launder
fighting money laundering
is of course a a big priority for us we
support international organizations
like fatah in uh in in this fight and of
course we would encourage
all countries including pakistan to
focus their efforts on implementing
any measures that have been set out by
fata to tackle this
thank you and your second question
related to pakistan on gsp plus
i'll give the photo here yes thank you
we can only say that we take note of the
ap resolution as we are still
analyzing the situation we cannot
comment further at this stage
okay thank you we are slightly running
out of time
so i go back to hans for his question on
a completely unrelated subject
guns well thank you eric it's actually i
guess for you
um i'd just like to know whether you
have a comment on
uh the letter and the call from from uh
renew europe president um or leader
darmian scholars
for the commission not to grant hungary
the recovery
fund at this stage unless the commission
unless sorry hungry at least gives
access to
ola for to to show yeah who are all the
beneficiaries of uh this recovery fund
money
in hungary so there's been this call to
the commission i'd like to get a
reaction from you thank you
thank you of course we are aware of the
letter that you mentioned
and and i believe that we have processes
in place
in terms of assessing the national
recovery plans
which will ensure that the management
and control systems that are put
in place are fully adequate and ensure
that the money goes to the beneficiaries
that are foreseen by the actual actions
of the plan
i will give the floor to marta in case
she has anything to add on this
thank you very much so indeed as you
know we have received the hungarian plan
and we are now
engaging in an in-depth assessment of
this plan against the 11 criteria of the
regulation
and as you know perhaps one of the
criteria of this regulation is that the
plan must provide an
adequate control and audit mechanism and
this is obviously something that we are
looking at very carefully
for all the plans we received so far you
can see in the assessments that we have
already published last week
on this issue and of course we will be
very carefully
assessing this point as well for hungary
as for all the other member states
and just to recall the recovery and
resilience facility provides
for a control framework that is
tailor-made
for this purpose member states we need
to explain
what are the arrangements they put in
place in the recovery and resilience
plan
and the commission will assess whether
these control systems provide sufficient
assurances
and of course if the control system is
deemed insufficient the
plan will be rejected of course at this
stage i will not be able to comment on
details
on on our assessment of the hungarian
plan which is still ongoing
but let me just recall that the
commission
um will obviously sorry check
carefully the fact that the control
systems are in place
and again member states will need to
collect data on the final recipients of
the funds
the contractors the subcontractors and
the beneficial owners
and make this available upon request
thank you
thank you very much uh and marta take it
easy when you go up those steps
don't go too quickly uh in your state
you have to take your time
okay um i see um
i will take one last question uh today
from moses
before we move to the press conference
to the president yes
eric it's related question to the
previous question
which concerned the aml that is
anti-money lawyering and also ctf
counter terrorist funding as you perhaps
know european court orders published not
or will publish today a report
is audited on anti-money laundering
measures
on air level especially about the
transposition or the lack of
transposition
of the current directive against money
laundering
and you'll probably see in the report
and what the
court orders complained about the kids
was the lack of a legal
level playing field in their member
states
it's not clear from the commission's
reply where the commission
intends let's say to
propose a new law regulation against
money laundering in its action plan
which is published last year or whether
it somehow will
accompany a kind of revised directive
as it said in reply could you please
clarify
what is the commission's position of
this thank you
thank you i believe this is a question
for dan
yeah absolutely thanks eric and i'm jose
um mosey listen i think you are a little
bit ahead of yourself
as you said the press release by the
court of austria is only going to
publish this afternoon so i'm not going
to comment on something that's not yet
public
and let me just make one or two very
very quick points on
anti-money laundering as i said this is
a this is a key priority
for us in the commission we are working
to overhaul
our rules and the strength of our rules
rely
almost entirely on the effect of
implementation of those rules
in member states and that's why we do
follow up and if you look at any of
our infringement cycles every month you
will see the
the measures that we are taking there
against member states who have not
properly implemented
those rules so effective effective
implementation
is central to um our fight against money
laundering
having common structures and increasing
our cooperation between all the
different
anti-money laundering authorities within
the european union is key to
all of that and that's actually the
whole point of our upcoming aml
package allowing us to better detect the
illicit flows of money and
and everything like that improving
coordination and improving the work
of our authorities within the european
union so
that's what i say by way of a general
comment and for a specific comment you
can get back to me
once the press release is published
thank you i'll take one last question in
fact from matthieu
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the
merci beaucoup